>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, NOW IT'S
TIME TO PLAY REACTION GIFS.
REACTION GIFS.
SOMETIMES YOU'RE ON THE INTERNET
AND YOU'RE AT A LOSS FOR WORDS
AND THE BEST WAY TO EXPRESS YOUR
JOY, SADNESS, OR FRUSTRATION OF
IDENTIFYING THE COLOR OF A
GODDAMN DRESS IS THROUGH A
REACTION GIF.
SO COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW
YOU A REACTION GIF AND FOR 250
POINTS, I WANT YOU TO COMPLETE
THE SENTENCE.
OK, THAT'S MY REACTION WHEN ...
FIRST ONE.
HOW ABOUT THIS SUPER SATISFIED
DUDE, HUH.
MATT.
>> THAT'S MY REACTION WHEN I
FINISH ALL OF THE BREADSTICKS.
>> Chris: POINTS. KEVIN.
>> THAT'S MY REACTION WHEN I
COMPLETE UNASSISTED
MASTURBATION.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NOW CAN YOU DO A HANDS-FREE?
>> YEAH.
I THINK REALLY HARD AND THEN --
>> Chris: WHAT ABOUT THESE TWO
LAUGHING OFFICERS.
WHAT ABOUT THEM?
THESE ARE YOUR TWO BUDDIES HERE.
YOU'VE GOT THE CARD UP THERE.
YOU'RE GOT NUMBER ONE.
>> CHRIS, THAT'S MY REACTION
WHEN THEY ASK WOULD LIKE
UNLIMITED BREADSTICKS.
WHO ARE THEY KIDDING? OF COURSE
I DO.
>> Chris: OKAY, POINTS. CHOBOT.
>> THAT'S MY REACTION WHEN
SOMEONE SAYS THEY GO TO A STAR
TREK CONVENTION AND THEN GOT
LAID.
>> Chris: NO. THAT WOULD BE
MATT.
I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT.
THAT'S MY REACTION WHEN MATT
TELLS ME HE'S SEEING "CHAPPIE"
ALL WEEKEND.
NEXT ONE.
WHAT ABOUT THIS SILVER FOX.
YES, KEVIN.
>> THAT WOULD BE MY REACTION
WHEN SOMEONE TELLS ME COMEDY
CENTRAL ROAST OF JUSTIN BIEBER
DOES NOT NVOLVE FIRE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ARE YOU SURE.
MATT MIRA.
>> IT'S MY REACTION WHEN THE
WAITRESS ASKED AM I FINISHED
WITH THE BREADSTICKS.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
I LIKE THAT MATT MIRA'S
@MIDNIGHT STRATEGY -- CHAPTER
ONE: CHAPPIE.
CHAPTER TWO: BREADSTICKS.
>> I LIKE IT! HE COMMITS.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, HOW ABOUT
THIS MAN CHILD?
HOW ABOUT THIS MAN CHILD.
MATT MIRA.
>> THAT'S MY REACTION WHEN THEY
TRY TO TELL ME WHAT ELSE IN ON
THE MENU BESIDES BREADSTICKS.
>> Chris: OKAY, POINTS.
AND GO [BLEEP] YOURSELF... WITH
A BREADSTICK.
I HOPE YOU GET [BEEP] WITH A
BREADSTICK BY CHAPPIE.
>> I JUST WANNA SAY, CHRIS, I
HOPE YOU ALSO ACHIEVE YOUR
DREAMS.
>> Chris: HE'S RIGHT. HE'S
RIGHT.
KEVIN.
>> THAT WAS MY REACTION BEFORE
THE SHOW WHEN MATT WAS LIKE I'M
COMMITTING TO BREADSTICKS.
>> Chris: POINTS. POINTS.
SO GOOD.